I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. It's The Duel. I mean, two men are gonna fight over me today. Me, aka Angela Martin. I have to say, like Andy's Prius, this episode sneaked up on me. But in a great way. Oh my gosh, hidden gem. It's so good. It's one of my favorite episodes. I loved watching it. I loved filming it. And I'm excited to talk about it today. Well, it is season 5, episode 12, written by
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作独家的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。这就是决斗。我的意思是，今天有两个男人要为我争风吃醋。我，也就是安吉拉·马丁。我得说，就像安迪的普锐斯一样，这一集悄悄地找上了我。但感觉真棒。哦天哪，隐藏的宝藏。太棒了。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我很喜欢看它。我也很喜欢拍摄它。我很兴奋今天能谈论它。好吧，这是第五季第十二集，编剧是
Jen Salada and directed by Dean Holland. Here's your summary. Michael takes it upon himself to expose Angela and Dwight's affair to Andy. The two men then challenge one another to a duel in the parking lot. Meanwhile, Michael is summoned to corporate to speak with David Wallace. He thinks it's gonna be bad news, but he gets some unexpected praise. Oh, those scenes. We'll get to it. But man, those are good too. Fast fact number one, this episode was written by the always amazing Jen Salada. Applause for Jen. Oh, Jen. Jen, so many good lines in this. I reached out to Jen and she sent in an audio clip explaining the inspiration behind this episode. Let's hear it. My biggest memory about writing The Duel was how little I had when I was sent off to write the script. It was
简·萨拉达，导演是迪恩·霍兰德。这是剧情简介。迈克尔自作主张向安迪揭发了安吉拉和德怀特的私情。这两个男人随后在停车场向对方发起决斗。与此同时，迈克尔被召集到总公司与大卫·华莱士谈话。他以为会是坏消息，但他得到了一些意料之外的赞扬。哦，那些场景。我们待会儿会说到。不过天哪，那些也很棒。趣事一号，这一集是由一如既往优秀的简·萨拉达编剧的。为简鼓掌。哦，简。简，这里面有好多精彩的台词。我联系了简，她发来一段音频剪辑，解释了这一集背后的灵感。我们来听听看。我关于创作《决斗》最大的记忆就是，当我被派去写剧本时，我手头的素材太少了。那是
mid-season five. It was a really busy patch for the writers, for all of us. And I remember this episode had to be written really, really quickly. And I knew it was about Andy finding out about Angela and Dwight's affair. But where we'd usually spend time as a group fleshing out the story, I went off on the script with a sentence. Andy runs over Dwight and his Prius, keeping it under five miles an hour so Dwight doesn't hear him coming. I mean, it was a good sentence, but there was a lot to fill in. That was it. She had a sentence. And she crafted this amazing story. Yes. Why Andy was going to run over Dwight slowly with a Prius? She didn't know. She just knew that was going to happen in the episode and this is what she came up with. She had to build to that
第五季中期。对编剧们来说，对我们所有人来说，那都是非常忙碌的一段时期。我记得这一集必须非常非常快地写完。我知道内容是关于安迪发现了安吉拉和德怀特的私情。但我们通常会作为团队花时间丰富故事的地方，我拿着一句话就开始写剧本了。安迪开着普锐斯撞倒了德怀特，车速控制在每小时五英里以下，这样德怀特就听不到他靠近。我的意思是，这是一句好句子，但有太多内容需要填充了。就是这样。她只有一句话。而她编织出了这样一个精彩的故事。是的。安迪为什么要用普锐斯缓慢地撞倒德怀特？她不知道。她只知道这一集里会发生这件事，而这就是她想出来的。她必须为那个
moment. Because usually they would get whole outlines. They would have an A plot, a B plot, all of it. No. Amazing. Jen Solana again. Amazing. That was Jen. Amazing. Fast fact number two. This episode was directed by Dean Holland. Dean was our other editor alongside Dave Rogers. We love Dean. Yes. We love Dean and he knew the show so well, much like Dave. They knew every moment. Oh yeah. Dean told me that he had directed something for MTV, but that this was his first time directing an episode of television. He was so nervous that he threw up in the bathroom at crew call. When he texted me that I was like, are you joking? He said, no, I'm being serious. I vomited in the bathroom. He said that it was really daunting because he had come from editing
时刻做铺垫。因为通常他们会得到完整的剧情大纲。他们会有一条主线剧情、一条支线剧情，全套都有。没有。太惊艳了。再次感谢简·索拉达。太惊艳了。那是简。太惊艳了。趣事二号。这一集是由迪恩·霍兰德执导的。迪恩是我们除了戴夫·罗杰斯之外的另一位剪辑师。我们爱迪恩。是的。我们爱迪恩，他非常了解这部剧，就像戴夫一样。他们了解每一个时刻。哦，是的。迪恩告诉我，他曾为MTV执导过一些东西，但这是他第一次执导电视剧的一集。他紧张得在工作人员集合时在洗手间吐了。当他给我发短信说这个时，我当时想，你在开玩笑吗？他说，没有，我是认真的。我在洗手间吐了。他说这真的让人感到畏惧，因为他是从剪辑转过来的，
and he hadn't spent a lot of time on set. You know, editor's life is very isolating. They're just in their editing room. And while we would pop over and say, hello, it's very different than how a set works. And he said he felt a little bit like a stranger in a strange land. Those were his words. But he also said he'd consulted a little bit with Paul Feig, but more than anything, he did a ton of prep work for this episode. He said he knew the script inside and out and listened to this. He said it changed very little from our table read. So that was good because he had been prepping and prepping on that table read draft. And a lot of times, you know, after the table read, they'll come back and whole scenes are gone and new plots. But no, he said he was really happy
而且他没有花太多时间在片场。你知道，剪辑师的生活非常孤立。他们只是待在剪辑室里。虽然我们会串门打个招呼，但这和片场的运作方式非常不同。他说他感觉自己有点像异乡异客。那是他的原话。但他也说他向保罗·费格征求了一些意见，不过最重要的是，他为这一集做了大量的准备工作。他说他对剧本烂熟于心，听听这个。他说剧本跟我们围读时几乎没有改动。所以这很好，因为他一直在对那个围读草稿进行各种准备。而且很多时候，你知道，围读之后，他们会回来，整场戏都没了，还会有新的剧情。但并没有，他说他真的很高兴
that not a lot changed. But I think again, Jen Salada clearly nailed this one from the beginning. She nailed it. So here's a little secret that Randy Cordray told me, Angela. You know, he's our line producer and he's in charge of setting the schedule for the directors. Yeah. So he must have known when Dean was directing. He manipulated the schedule so that Dean would get this episode because when he read it, he thought Dean would be perfect to direct it. Oh my gosh, Randy, look at you working it. Yeah. He said he really wanted Dean to get this one for his directorial debut. I mean, what a gift. Wow. Well, this was a really big episode, you know, for the whole love triangle. The Dwight, Andy, Angela was all coming to a head and I was nervous
没有发生太大的改动。但我想说，简·萨拉达从一开始就显然把这一集拿捏得死死的。她拿捏得太准了。所以这里有个兰迪·科德雷告诉我的小秘密，安吉拉。你知道的，他是我们的制片主任，负责为导演排班。是的。所以他一定知道迪恩什么时候当导演。他操纵了日程安排，好让迪恩能拍这一集，因为当他读完剧本后，他认为迪恩是执导这一集的绝佳人选。哦天哪，兰迪，瞧你这小算盘打得。是的。他说他真的很想让迪恩的导演处女作拍这一集。我的天，多棒的礼物啊。哇。好吧，这真的是一集非常重大的剧集，你知道的，为了整个三角恋。德怀特、安迪、安吉拉的关系终于要迎来了结，其实我当时对这一集感到很紧张。
actually about this episode. I just knew that I wanted to play these moments, right? And that was a tricky kind of scenario, Jenna, because like Angela is worried about both of them and feeling guilt. But also, I don't know, is she turned on? I don't know. It's a lot happening. And I felt very safe knowing Dean was directing me this week because like we knew him. You know what I mean? Yes. And I could go up to him and be like, Dean, did I do that right? What do you think? Should I try something else? So I felt very happy to have Dean there for the duel. Well, shortly after this, he went over to do Parks and Rec. He was the editor over there. Yeah. He directed a bunch of episodes there. But then years later, I got to be reunited with him because he was the executive
我只知道我想把这些时刻演对。珍娜，那是一种很棘手的剧本情境，因为安吉拉既为他们两个担心，又怀有负罪感。但同时，我不知道，她是不是被撩到了？我不知道。发生了太多事。而且我知道迪恩这周在指导我，这让我感到非常安心，因为我们了解他。你知道我的意思吗？是的。我可以走到他面前说，迪恩，我那样演对吗？你觉得呢？我应该尝试点别的吗？所以在决斗这场戏里有迪恩在，我感到非常高兴。好吧，不久之后，他去拍了《公园与游憩》。他是那里的剪辑师。是的。他在那里执导了好多集。但几年后，我有幸与他重聚，因为他是我在ABC的节目《共分母》的执行制片人和导演。是的。然后我得以去客串了你的节目。我还见到了迪恩和我们的音效部门。就像一个迷你的《办公室》重聚。我喜欢那一天。那是个有趣的日子。确实。好了。趣事三号，决斗的历史。什么？哦，不。你电脑的搜索历史里都有些什么？哦，不。首先，我只想说我不是历史学家。我只是一个会用谷歌的女士。你只是一个热爱谷歌的可爱女士。没错。但关于决斗这个主题，我确实读了四到五个看起来挺权威的网站。好吧。以下是我整理的内容。好吧。决斗似乎起源于中世纪的欧洲。贵族们会通过一对一的战斗来捍卫他们的
producer and director of my show over at ABC, splitting up together. Yes. And then I got to come and do a guest spot on your show. And I got to see Dean and our sound department. It was like a mini office reunion. I loved that day. It was a fun day. It was. All right. Fast fact number three, the history of dueling. What? Oh, no. What is your search history on your computer? Oh, no. First of all, I would just like to say I am not a historian. I'm just a lady with Google. You're just a delightful lady that loves to Google. That's right. But I did read about four to five what seemed like reputable websites on the subject of dueling. Okay. And here is what I have pulled together. Okay. Dueling seems to have originated in medieval Europe. Nobles would defend their
荣誉。好吧，听着，如果你看过《古战场传奇》，你就知道这是真的。我没看。拜访啦，拜访啦，萨萨纳克。拜访啦。好吧，在1777年，一群爱尔兰人将决斗习俗编纂成册。他们写了一份规则文件，听听他们是怎么叫它的。他们叫它决斗法典。决斗法典。我敢肯定那是你可以点到的一种甜点。我要一份决斗法典，谢谢。我喜欢柠檬味的。它包含26条非常具体的规则，概述了决斗的方方面面，包括可以接受挑战的时间段，以及获胜所需的开枪次数或负伤次数。我觉得德怀特一定知道这26条决斗规则，因为他掌握了所有施鲁特男孩在五岁之前必须学习的40条规则。
honor in man to man battles. Well, listen, if you watch Outlander, you know that's true. I don't. Come on. Come on, Sasanek. Come on. Well, in 1777, a group of Irishmen codified the dueling practices. They wrote a document of rules and listened to what they called it. They called it Code Duelo. Code Duelo. I'm pretty sure that's the type of dessert you can get. I'll have the Code Duelo, thanks. I love the lemon flavor. It consisted of 26 very specific rules outlining all aspects of the duel, including the time of day during which challenges could be received, the number of shots or wounds required in order to win. I feel like Dwight would have known these 26 rules of dueling because he had the 40 rules all shrewt boys have to learn before their five.
他热爱规则。我觉得德怀特知道这些决斗规则。他肯定知道。对吧？他建议决斗的。哦，我确信他知道。我确信其中一些规则已经融入了施鲁特的生活方式中。融入了施鲁特的40条规则里？是的。美国有记录的第一场决斗发生在1621年的马萨诸塞湾殖民地。好吧。然后美国创建了他们自己的一套决斗规则。哦。它们是由南卡罗来纳州州长约翰·威尔逊于1838年编写的。所以在典型的美国决斗中，双方都必须通过副手（秒）行动。每个人，我是从音乐剧《汉密尔顿》里知道这一点的。对，对，对。哦，就像你有你的同伴跟你一起去。是的。你有一个副手。没错。对，对，对。而且你不是还可以带个随行军医，比如医生吗？哦，那是
He loves rules. I feel like Dwight knows about these dueling rules. He must. Right? He suggested the duel. Oh, I'm sure he knew. I'm sure that some of these rules have made their way into the shrewt life. Into the shrewt 40 rules? Yes. The first recorded duel in America took place in 1621 in the Massachusetts Bay Colony. Okay. And then America created their own set of dueling rules. Oh. They were written by South Carolina Governor John Wilson in 1838. So in a typical American duel, each party has to act through a second. I know this from the musical Hamilton, everyone. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, like you have your partner that goes with you. Yes. You have a second. That's right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And don't you get to bring like a medic, like a doctor? Oh, that's an
《古战场传奇》里的。没事。杰米会把萨萨纳克带在身边。好吧。没关系。继续。我不太清楚那个。好吧。我只读了四到五个网站。好吧。如果我们有一位历史学家，也许他们会知道。你应该看《古战场传奇》，但别带着你的孩子们一起看。好吧。所以听着，如果一个男人觉得自己受到了侮辱，他会告诉他的副手去向冒犯者下战书要求决斗。你不能自己去。你得派你的副手去。副手的主要职责是试图促成和解，避免暴力。哦，所以那个人就像是调解员。是的，我的意思是，他们实际上在做所有治疗师都告诉我们不要做的事情，那就是通过三角定位沟通来解决冲突，不过管他呢，这就是决斗。
outlander. Never mind. Jamie would bring Sasanac with him. Okay. Never mind. Go. I don't know about that. Okay. I only read four to five websites. Okay. If we have a historian, perhaps they would know. You should watch Outlander, but don't watch it with your children around. Okay. So listen, if a man felt like his honor had been insulted, he would tell his second to challenge the offender to a duel. You do not do it yourself. You send your second. The main duty of the second is to try to create a reconciliation, to avoid violence. Oh, so that person's like the mediator. Yeah, I mean, they're literally doing what all therapists tell us not to do, which is to triangulate communication in order to, you know, solve conflicts, but whatever, this is dueling.
我是我们家的副手。我经常是被派去平息其他问题的那个人。我想很多人在家里都有这个定位。我懂。但如果副手去了并说，嘿，我的当事人被你冒犯了，想要跟你决斗，而对方说，太好了，我们决斗吧，那么决斗挑战的接受者就可以挑选武器、时间和决斗地点。例如，伊利诺伊州总检察长詹姆斯·希尔兹向未来的总统亚伯拉罕·林肯发起了决斗。哦天哪。林肯接受了决斗，他选择了阔剑作为他们的武器。詹姆斯·希尔兹当时就想，什么鬼？这太疯狂了。算了。忘了吧。然后他取消了决斗。所以林肯这招很大胆，
I'm the second in my family. I'm often the person sent in to smooth over the other stuff. I think a lot of people have that position in their family. I get it. But if the second goes and said, hey, my guy is offended by you and wants to duel, and the person says, great, we're dueling, the recipient of the duel challenge gets to pick the weapons and the time and the place of the duel. So for example, James Shields and Illinois Attorney General challenged future President Abraham Lincoln to a duel. Oh my gosh. Lincoln accepted the duel and he chose the broad sword as their weapon. James Shields was like, what the F? That's insane. Never mind. Forget it. And he called off the duel. So like bold move by Lincoln,
林肯的意思是，我会出现，而且我会带着我的剑去决斗。你想要吗？林肯当时的想法是：我个子高，而且我还是个剑客。是的。詹姆斯·希尔兹就觉得：算了吧。你知道吗？我挺好的。你知道吗？我想过了，我没关系。还有这个。这个真的把我惊艳到了。我猜安德鲁·杰克逊以决斗闻名。这家伙有超多决斗。专家估计他的决斗次数可能高达100场。100场。安德鲁当时是在惹恼每一个人吗？他就是在惹恼所有人。每个人都想跟他干一架。他最著名的一场决斗是和查尔斯·迪金森，不要跟作家查尔斯·迪金森搞混了。哦，我还想说，你看到我脸上的表情了吗？我当时想，等等，什么？
Lincoln's like, I'll show up and I'm bringing my sword to the duel. Do you want it? Lincoln was like, I'm tall and I'm a swordsman. Yeah. James Shields was like, never mind. You know what? I'm good. You know what? I thought about it and I'm okay. Here's one. This one really got me. I guess Andrew Jackson was very famous for dueling. Lots of duels this guy. Experts placed his number of duels maybe as many as 100. 100. Was Andrew just pissing everyone off? He was just pissing everyone off. Everyone wanted to fight him. His most famous duel was with Charles Dickinson, not to be confused with Charles Dickinson, the writer. Oh, I was going to say, did you see my look on my face? I was like, wait, what?
对。不是。查尔斯·迪金森，他是个马匹繁殖者，我猜这俩人恨透了彼此。迪金森指责杰克逊在一场赛马赌局中作弊，并向杰克逊下了决斗战书。杰克逊的回应是：我准时到。武器是手枪。但问题是。迪金森被公认是全国枪法最好的神枪手之一。所以我不知道为什么安德鲁·杰克逊会选择手枪，但他确实选了。我想也许那就是，我不知道，某种气势或者别的什么，对吧？所以他们出现了。他们决斗了。是的。迪金森开了第一枪。子弹击中了安德鲁·杰克逊的胸口。他胸口流血了。好吧。所有记录都表明他用一只手按住伤口，举起手枪，向迪金森开枪。他的手枪卡壳了。没打响。哦。所以安德鲁
Yeah. No. Charles Dickinson, he was a horse breeder and I guess these two guys hated each other. Dickinson accused Jackson of cheating on a horse bet and he challenged Jackson to a duel. Jackson was like, I'll be there. The weapon is pistols. But here's the thing. Dickinson was like known to be one of the best shots in the nation. So I don't know why Andrew Jackson picked pistols, but he did. I think maybe that was just, I don't know, some swagger or something, right? So they show up. They duel. Yeah. Dickinson got off the first shot. It hit Andrew Jackson in the chest. He's bleeding from the chest. Okay. All accounts are that he like held one hand to the wound, lifted his pistol, fired at Dickinson. His pistol misfired. It didn't shoot. Oh. So Andrew
杰克逊重新扳动击锤，再次开枪，打死了迪金森。这非常有争议，安吉拉。按照决斗规则，你只能开枪一次。我正想这么说呢。你们不是只能开一枪就结束吗？我对决斗一无所知，但我很确信情况是这样的。谢谢你，《汉密尔顿》。是的。我不知道。安德鲁·杰克逊活了下来。他逃脱了惩罚，后来还当选了美国总统。我有个问题。什么问题？如果你是查尔斯·迪金森。没错。你看到安德鲁·杰克逊把枪指向你。对。准备开枪。你会走S形路线逃跑吗？你能躲开还是只能站在那里？祈祷上帝保佑，子弹不会击中你？难道不允许走位吗？我不能跳来跳去吗？我不知道。我不知道。因为我
Jackson recocked his pistol, fired again and killed Dickinson. This was very controversial, Angela. In the rules of dueling, you only get to fire once. That's what I was going to say. Aren't you one and done? And I know nothing about dueling, but I was pretty sure that's the case. Thank you, Hamilton. Yeah. I don't know. Andrew Jackson lived. He got away with it and was later elected president of the United States. I have a question. What is it? If you're Charles Dickinson. Yep. You see Andrew Jackson pointing his gun at you. Right. To fire. Do you run a zigzag? Can you step out of the way or do you just have to stand there? Fingers crossed, it doesn't hit you. Is there no movement allowed? Can I not jump around? I don't know. I don't know. Because I'm
才不会站在原地不动呢。如果你用手枪指着我，我肯定要跑起来。是的。我想你是不被允许这么做的，安吉。哦。美国有记录的最后一场决斗是在1859年。好吧。参与者都有谁？是不是又是两个白人男人互相射击？当然是的，女士。不仅如此，其中一个是美国参议员，另一个是加利福尼亚州最高法院的退休首席大法官。哦。干得漂亮，各位。这场决斗没有人死，因为，听听这个疯狂的事：其中一个人的枪卡壳了。好吧。然后另一个人开枪了，但子弹打中了对方的黄金怀表，于是他们鸣金收兵了。就是这样。那是美国的最后一场决斗。好吧。现在，如果安德鲁·杰克逊在那儿，他早就把枪修好然后再朝你开枪了
not going to stand in one place. If you're pointing a pistol at me, I'm going to get moving. Yeah. I think you're not allowed, Ange. Oh. The last duel of record in the United States was in 1859. Okay. Here's who it involved. Was it more white men shooting at each other? It sure was, lady. Not only that, it was a United States senator and a retired chief justice of the California Supreme Court. Oh. Way to go, guys. No one died in this duel because, listen to this madness, one guy's gun jammed. Okay. And then the other guy fired his gun, but it hit the other guy in his gold pocket watch and they called a truce. There you go. That was the last duel in America. Yeah. All right. Now, if Andrew Jackson was there, he would have unjammed his gun and shot at you
。对。是的。我想说，我不知道安德鲁·杰克逊的副手是谁，但我认为他们干得真够烂的。那迪金森的副手呢？迪金森的副手曾试图辩称，你知道的，我认为安德鲁·杰克逊应该以谋杀罪接受审判，但没有人愿意听这些。这非常有趣。我很喜欢你所有的决斗冷知识。谢谢你。我很享受研究我的决斗冷知识。我的意思是，我内心深处其实很想和你一起做一个历史播客，但我们总是把每件事都稍微弄错一点。好吧，我们已经在这么做了。我敢肯定，在趣事三号里，我至少有12件事弄错了。你知道吗？这就像是我们版本的《醉酒史》，只不过我们没喝酒。
again. Right. Yeah. I would like to say, I don't know who Andrew Jackson's second was, but I think they did a real shitty job. What about Dickinson's second? Dickinson's second tried to make a case that, you know, Andrew Jackson I think should be tried for murder, but no one wanted to hear about it. That was very interesting. I liked all your dual trivia. Thank you. I enjoyed researching my dual trivia. I mean, there is just a part of me that would do a history podcast with you, but we get everything slightly wrong. Well, we're already doing that. I'm sure there are at least 12 things I did wrong in this fast fact number three. You know what? It's like our version of drunk history, but we're not drunk.
是的。我们只是满怀好意、喜欢用谷歌搜索并给你讲历史的女士们。好吧。我们要休息一下吗？我想我们应该休息一下。关于这一集有太多内容要说了，我已经迫不及待了。好吧。这一集的开头是一个精彩的Cold Open（片头前小品）。拍摄过程太有趣了。我又看了一遍，还是很喜欢。我也是。电话铃响了，潘接了电话。有人找迈克尔，但迈克尔不在。迈克尔去哪儿了？哦，迈克尔在街上。他在跑步。他在大喊大叫。那里有一个测速雷达标志，他一次又一次地从旁边跑过，试图看看自己能跑多快。这就是迈克尔今天早上的所作所为。这就是迈克尔在做的事。我们都在纳闷为什么。好吧，潘透露，安吉拉显然曾多次拨打911，举报马路上的车速太快
Yes. We're just well-meaning ladies who Google and tell you history. All right. Should we take a break? I think we should. There's a lot to say about this episode and I can't wait. All right. This episode opens with an amazing cold open. It was so much fun to shoot. I loved watching it again. Me too. The phone rings, Pam answers the phone. Someone for Michael, but Michael's not there. Where is Michael? Oh, Michael is down on the street. He's running. He's screaming. There is a speed radar sign and he keeps running past it trying to see how fast he can go. That's what Michael's doing this morning. That's what Michael's doing. We're all wondering why. Well, Pam shares that Angela has apparently called 911 several times to report cars going too fast
了。于是警察就来竖起了这样一种雷达屏幕，对吧？就是能显示你车速的那种。是的。不过，我猜这其实是一场很难拍摄的戏。真的吗？是的。迪恩告诉我，我们必须在两个不同的地方拍摄。所以你在窗外看到的迈克尔跑步的任何画面，我们都必须在保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室里拍摄。哦，好吧。因为那是能看到我们的停车场和街道的窗户。但当然，所有其他在室内的戏，我们都必须在邓德米弗林内部拍摄。顺便说一句，这个稍后还会提到。是的。所以迪恩告诉我，对于开场潘接电话然后镜头拉回到迈克尔空办公室的那一刻，
outside on the road. And so the police came and put up this sort of like that radar screen, right? That tells you your speed. Yes. Well, I guess though, this was a really hard scene to shoot. Really? Yeah. Dean told me that we had to shoot this in two different places. So anything that you see out the window of Michael running, we had to shoot that from Paul Lieberstein's office. Oh, okay. Because that was the window that looked outside onto our parking lot and onto our street. But of course, everything else that was indoors, we had to shoot inside Dunder Mifflin. And by the way, this is going to come up again later. Yeah. So Dean told me that for that opening moment where Pam is on the phone and then the camera pulls back into Michael's empty office,
然后镜头猛地转向窗户，你看到迈克尔在跑步。是的。他必须使用那种甩镜头（whip cut）。所以他拍了潘，拉回到迈克尔的办公室，然后甩到一个窗户上，那窗户后面其实只有一个纱幕（scrim），对吧？因为迈克尔的办公室本来就是那样的。是的。是的。在我们的片场，他窗户后面什么也没有。是的。然后他走到保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室。他又做了一个甩镜头，让史蒂夫在外面跑过，然后他把那个甩镜头剪辑到一起，组合了起来。这就是电影魔术，各位。电影魔术。现在，我猜每个人都决定他们想知道自己能跑多快。感觉像是迈克尔逼着我们所有人都去外面从那个标志旁跑过。德怀特非常热情。他很高兴从那儿跑过。他跑过去，测出了
and then it whips over to the window and you see Michael running. Yeah. He had to use one of those whip cuts. So he shot Pam, pulled back into Michael's office, and then he whipped to a window that just had like a scrim behind it, right? Because that's what Michael's office really has. Yeah. Yeah. On our set, there's nothing behind his window. Yeah. Then he went up to Paul Lieberstein's office. He did another whip and then had Steve run by outside and he did that thing where he cut in the whip and put it together. That's movie magic, guys. Movie magic. Now, I guess everyone has decided they want to know how fast they can run. It feels like Michael has forced us all outside to run past the sign. Dwight is very enthusiastic. He's happy to run past it. He runs past and he
每小时13英里的速度。是的。好吧，珍娜，你注意到我们大家看起来都是那样的吗，我们都好冷，而且在瑟瑟发抖？但实际上，小伙子们却在疯狂冒汗。哦，是的。我去查了天气，因为我只是个喜欢了解天气状况的老太太。我显然已经变成我父母那样的人了，因为在我父母家里，电视总是开着，而且总是锁定在气象频道。如果你想知道任何地方的天气，只要给我妈妈打电话就行。她会告诉你。所以我翻出了我的数字杂物堆，发现我们是在2008年10月13日那一周拍摄这一集的，那周的平均气温高达90多华氏度（约30多摄氏度）。兰迪告诉我，那天不仅气温超过了90度，而且我们还必须把这场戏安排在午饭后立即拍摄。
gets a speed of 13 miles per hour. Yes. Well, Jenna, do you notice how we're all just like, we're so cold and we're like shivering? But truly, the guys are like sweating their butts off. Oh, yeah. I went to because I'm just an old lady who loves to know what the weather was. I've clearly become my parents because at my parents' house, the TV is always on and it's always on the weather channel. If you need to know what the weather is anywhere, just call my mom. She'll tell you. So I dug into my digital clutter and found out we shot this episode the week of October 13th in 2008 and the average temperature was in the 90s for this week. Randy told me that, yeah, not only was it over 90 degrees that day, but we had to schedule this scene to shoot right after
哦，真糟糕。所以我们都吃得饱饱的，太阳就直直地挂在我们头顶上。是的。但他说，幸运的是，这只花了几个小时就拍完了。几个小时。我知道。我们算幸运的。哦天哪，我总是为小伙子们感到难过。这是我唯一一次为小伙子们感到难过，因为我们在片场冻得屁股冰凉。女士们是的。我们的衣服总是穿得比较少。但当我们拍这些停车场戏时，他们穿着厚重的西装，汗流浃背，而且肚子里装满食物还在奔跑。我得想象我们在那个90度的停车场里其实挺舒服的。我可能挺好的。我们太棒了。所以天气很热，他们从那个测速雷达前跑过。德怀特跑了13分，而迈克尔想要打破这个纪录。
lunch. Oh, gross. So we all had these full bellies and the sun was right directly over us. Yeah. But he said, luckily, it only took a couple of hours to shoot. A couple of hours. I know. Lucky for us. Oh my, I always felt bad. This is the one moment I felt bad for the guys because we froze our butts off on the stage. The ladies did. We were always in less clothing. But then when we were in these parking lot scenes and they're in full suits and they're sweating their butts off and running with full stomachs of food. I have to imagine we were pretty comfortable out there in that 90 degree parking lot. I was probably fine. We were great. So it is hot and they're running past this radar gun. Dwight scored a 13 and Michael wants to beat it.
于是他开始重新奔跑，一辆车驶过，突然迈克尔测出了31英里的时速，他当时就想，耶。然后大家都觉得这纯属扯淡。是的。好吧，我们收到了很多关于我们是如何用技术手段弄出这些速度数字的问题。兰迪跟我们分享说，那台机器其实就是正常运转的。它实际上在测量人们真实的跑步速度和真实的汽车速度。但随后他跟我们分享了我们拍这个Cold Open的原因，灵感来自于我们的一位编剧的现实生活经历。是的。亚伦·舒尔，各位。亚伦总是能想出这些棒极了的Cold Open。我和他聊过。对我来说他太搞笑了，珍娜，因为他说，我猜我的现实生活刚好足够古怪，以至于能转化成一个精彩的Cold Open。
And so he starts running again and a car goes by and all of a sudden Michael clocks 31 and he's like, yes. And everyone kind of calls BS on that. Yes. Well, we got a lot of questions about how did we technically pull this off with these speed numbers. Randy shared with us that the machine just worked. It was actually clocking people's real running speeds and the real car speed. But then he shared with us the reason we did this cold open was inspired by one of our writers, real life experience. Yes. Aaron, sure, you guys. Aaron is always coming up with these great cold opens. And I talked with him. He is so hilarious to me, Jenna, because he's like, I guess my real life is just weird enough that it translates into a great cold open.
在加入《办公室》之前，亚伦曾在《俏妈新上路》工作。那是CBS的一档节目。是的，由茱莉亚·路易斯-德利法斯主演。没错。他们在华纳兄弟片场拍摄，他说在华纳兄弟片场，有一个这样的测速雷达枪。他和一些其他编剧从员工食堂吃完午饭往回走。当他走过那个测速雷达时，上面显示零。所以他就想，哦，是吗？于是他放下午餐，往后退，然后以最快的速度从它旁边跑过。出人意料的是，它测出的时速是20英里。这是他的记忆。那是他的记忆。他说其他编剧当时反应是，等等，我也想试试。他们往后退，也开始从它旁边跑过。他说那天下午编剧室里到处都是汗水。
Prior to working on the office, Aaron had been working on the new adventures of old Christine. It was a show on CBS. Yeah, with Julia Louis-Dreyfus. Exactly. They filmed on the Warner Brothers Lot and he said on the Warner Brothers Lot, there was this radar gun. And he was walking back from lunch from the commissary with some of the other writers. And as he walked past the radar gun, it said zero. So he was like, oh, yeah? So he set his lunch down, backed up, and he ran as fast as he could by it. Surprisingly, it clocked 20 miles per hour. That's his memory. That is his memory. He said other writers were like, wait, I want to try this. They backed up and they started running past it as well. And he said it was a very sweaty writer's room that afternoon.
这太不可思议了。所以当他来到《办公室》时，他讲了这段经历，大家都觉得，哦，天哪，这绝对是德怀特和迈克尔会做的事。肯定的。我们拍完这个之后，他们把那个测速仪搬到了靠近餐饮部的停车场，它就在那儿放了一整周的制作期。好吧，我猜这太诱人了，无法忽视。哦，不。兰迪说有一天午饭期间，一群编剧跑过去开始冲刺。我们又来了。但随后我猜发生了一件事故，女士。什么？还记得我们的编剧莱恩·柯吗？是的。我不记得有什么事故。是的。兰迪分享说，莱恩从测速仪旁跑过，结果不太妙。哦，不。所以我联系了莱恩来了解这个故事。而且女士，我没有告诉你
That is incredible. So he told this story when he came to the office and they were like, oh, my gosh, like this is something Dwight and Michael would do. For sure. After we were done filming this, they moved that speed meter onto the parking lot near catering and it sat there for the whole week of production. Well, I guess it was too tempting to ignore. Oh no. Randy said that one day during lunch, a bunch of the writers went down and they started sprinting past it. Here we go again. But then I guess there was an accident, lady. What? Remember our writer, Ryan Co. Yeah. I don't remember an accident. Yeah. Randy shared that Ryan ran past the speed meter and it didn't go well. Oh no. So I reached out to Ryan to get the story. And lady, I did not tell you
这个，因为我觉得你需要直接听他讲。当他给我发邮件时，我大喊了一声，哦，不。当我读他的邮件时，女士，他打进电话来给我们讲这个故事了。哦天哪，莱恩。好吧。他来了。所以莱恩，你是第五季编剧团队的一员。你写了《商业道德》。你写了《激烈竞争》。但你打电话来的原因是因为你有一个故事要讲。是的，我想是的。所以这一集的Cold Open是迈克尔和德怀特跑出，你的速度就像街上那种让你减速的标志。是的。没错。我们和亚伦·舒尔谈过这件事。所以我们对此记忆犹新，但我们不知道你也是赛跑的一员。哦，是的。所以我要说的是，
this because I think you need to hear it from him directly. When he emailed me, I literally shouted, oh no. As I was reading his email, he's calling in, lady, to tell us the story. Oh my gosh, Ryan. All right. Here he is. So Ryan, you were a member of the writing staff in season five. You wrote business ethics. You wrote heavy competition. But the reason you're calling is because you have a story to tell. Yeah, I guess so. So the cold open of this episode is Michael and Dwight running out of, your speed is like one of those signs that gets you to slow down on streets. Yes. Right. Right. We had spoke to Aaron Schur about this. So we remember it well and we did not know you were also part of the speed racing. Oh yeah. So I should say
兰迪·科德雷说过，在我们拍完这场戏后，他把测速仪放在了停车场，然后很多人，包括编剧和剧组人员，都决定下去玩这个从它旁边跑过的游戏。而你就是那些想跑过去的人之一。绝对的。是的。我在第四季时是个专职编剧，到了第五季时依然对自己的存在感到不安全。这是我向所有人证明我至少是最快的机会。你就是跑得最快的编剧。这就是你的高光时刻。是的。但你在高中时跑过田径，对吧？我在新英格兰地区百米赛跑中在我们那个非常小的学校组别里排名第六。哦天哪，莱恩，全新英格兰第六名？是在非常小的学校组别里。不过是的。所以我当时想，
Randy Cordray said that after we finished shooting this scene, he put the speed tracker in the parking lot and a bunch of people, writers and crew all decided to go down and do this thing where you run past it. And you were one of the people who wanted to run past it. Absolutely. Yeah. I was like a staff writer in season four and still like felt insecure about being there in season five. And this is my chance to prove everyone that I was at least the fastest. You were the fastest writer. This was your moment. Yes. But you ran track in high school, right? I was sixth in New England in the hundred and sort of our very small school division. Oh my God, Ryan, sixth in all of New England? In the very small schools. But yes. So I was like,
我要打败那些愚蠢的老编剧。所以告诉我们发生了什么。我今天早上重看那个Cold Open。然后就像史蒂夫和雷恩都跑出了每小时12和13英里的速度。是的。是的。然后几个编剧跑了，他们都跑出了每小时12英里的速度。然后我就想，哦，我可以打破那个纪录。所以我当时穿着灯芯绒裤子和查克·泰勒帆布鞋。你穿的是工作服。你根本没穿适合跑步的衣服。你穿的就是那天上班穿的衣服。好吧，兰迪只是探出头来说，谁想跟测速仪赛跑？然后我就说，好啊。所以，是的，我真的系紧了鞋带。我的意思是，它们是那种，它们有点宽松的查克鞋，有点像一脚蹬的鞋子。不管怎样，我把鞋带系得紧紧的。然后我开始
I'm going to beat stupid old writers. So tell us what happened. I rewatched the cold open this morning. And so like both Steve and Rain ran like 12 and 13 miles an hour. Yeah. Yeah. And then a couple of a couple writers ran and they all got like 12 miles an hour. And then I was like, oh, I can beat that. So I had on corduroy's and like Chuck Taylor's. You were just in your work clothes. You weren't like dressed to run. You were just in what you wore to work that day. Well, Randy just poked his head up and said like, who wants to run at a speedometer? And I'm like, yeah. So yeah, I like really laced up. I mean, they're, they're sort of loose fitting chucks and they're sort of like a slip on shoe. Anyway, I laced them up really tight. And then I started
奔跑。我有一种记忆，就像是昨天发生的一样，我不知道你有没有过这种经历：当你跑得很快时，然后你脚下突然没有了地面。你只是在双脚像风车一样空转，脚下却没有着力点。然后我非常清楚地记得看到，好吧，也不是很清楚，因为我记不清具体数字了，大概是17或18英里每小时，然后我就像飞到了空中，这对于参考来说就像是从高尔夫球车上被甩出去。不算太糟糕。然后，我的，我的灯芯绒裤子完全被撕裂了，从我的腿上撕了下来。所以我趴在手肘和前臂上滑行。丹·戈尔，当时观看的人之一，说你能看出我伤得有多重，因为我立刻从地上跳起来
running. And I, I have this memory like it was yesterday of, I don't know if you ever had this experience where you're running fast, and then there's no ground beneath your feet. And you're just sort of wind milling your feet with no ground underneath it. And then I very clearly remember seeing, well, not clearly, because I don't remember exactly, but it was like 17 or 18 miles an hour before I like sort of flew into the air, which for reference is like getting thrown out of a golf cart. It's not too bad. And then so like my, my quarter eyes totally shredded, shredded off my legs. So I laid it on my elbows and forearms. And Dan Gore, who was one of the people watching, said you could tell how it was really hurt because I immediately popped off the ground
说，我没事，我没事。这就是人们伤得很重时会做的事。但你确实伤得挺重。医疗人员确实过来处理了，对吧？我确实被“木乃伊化”了。大约一个小时后我还得去参加我表哥的婚礼。哦，不。他们用了，你知道的，那种，那种纱布，甚至都不是绷带，而是那种你能看透的纱布。对。他们把它紧紧缠在我受伤、皮开肉绽的手臂和腿上。然后我上了飞机。等我到达波特兰时，我走进药店买了一大堆不粘纱布之类的东西。然后我发现所有的伤口在绷带里已经结痂了。所以我站在淋浴下
and said like, I'm fine, I'm fine. This is what people do when they're really hurt. But you were pretty hurt. Like the medic did have to come over, right? I did get really mummified. I had to go to my cousin's wedding like an hour afterwards. Oh no. They used, you know, like that, that gauze, not even like bandage, but you know, that gauze that you can see through. Right. And they wrapped it all around my arms and legs, which were pretty skinned. And then I got on the plane. And then when I arrived in Portland, I went into the drugstore and bought a ton of like nonstick gauze and stuff. And then I had seen that all the scabs had formed like in the bandage anyway. So I stood in the shower for
站了一个小时，只是为了解开我那被裹成木乃伊的手臂，然后大叫一声好家伙。就在我摔倒后不久，我记得兰迪立刻就说，好了，把这个收起来。谁也不许再跑了。谁也不准……你知道的，他们可不想再有一个白痴对《办公室》提起诉讼。就是这样。我自己弄伤了自己。我四肢上现在都还有伤疤。哦天哪。算是挺像样的一个故事。但你赢了。你赢了。你测出了最高速度。所以至少还有这个。我觉得没人会叫我赢家，不过当然，我相信。勉强算吧。我绝对可以为我跑出最高速度这一事实作证。我的意思是，我通过让它被移除从而取消了所有人的资格，这也算帮了忙。也许这就是我的策略。测出一个高速，然后把自己弄得血肉模糊，这样他们
like an hour, just unwrapping my mummified arms and sort of yell a good thing. Right after I fell, I remember Randy immediately was like, all right, let's put this away. No one else. No one else. You know, they didn't want another idiot filing a lawsuit against the office. That was it. I hurt myself. I still have scars on all four of my limbs. Oh my gosh. Sort of a decent story. But you won. You won. You got the fastest speed. So there's that. I don't think anyone would call me the winner, but sure, I do believe. Sort of. I will definitely vouch for the fact that I got the fastest speed. I mean, I helped by disqualifying everyone by getting it removed. Maybe that was my strategy. Get a high speed and then mangle myself so they
就把测速仪拿走了。莱恩，谢谢你来到《办公室女士》并分享你的故事。如果我们聊到《激烈竞争》那一集时，我们需要一些冷知识，我们可能会再找你，你不介意吧？好的，听起来不错。好的。爱你，莱恩。有人跟你通话。保重。拜拜。拜拜。哦天哪。这就像是，艺术模仿生活，生活模仿艺术，然后艺术回归生活，是这样吗？太疯狂了。你还记得播客早期你说过生活在恐吓艺术吗？我记得，珍娜。我记得。感觉就像生活对莱恩·柯说：我要通过把你摔到柏油路上来恐吓你。生活在恐吓艺术。我想是的。生活把莱恩摔到了柏油路上，
get rid of the speedometer. Ryan, thank you for coming on Office Ladies and telling your story. We're going to hit you up for some trivia about heavy competition when we get to it, if you don't mind. Okay, sounds great. All right. Love you, Ryan. Somebody talking to you. Take care. Bye. Bye. Oh my gosh. This is like, it's art imitating life. Life imitating art and art back to life is that it? This is crazy. Do you remember early in the podcast when you said life intimidating art? I do, Jenna. I do. It feels like life said to Ryan Coe, I'm going to intimidate you by throwing you to the asphalt. Life is intimidating art. I think so. Life threw Ryan to the asphalt
以一种根据他的艺术创作而言非常具有恐吓性的方式。天哪。好吧，这就是Cold Open，各位，而我们甚至还没开始讲正片呢。我们开始吧，因为今天是重要的一天。对迈克尔来说是个大日子，因为大卫·华莱士想见他，跟他谈谈宏观层面的事。迈克尔其实不知道那意味着什么。这大概不是什么好事。这也是个大日子，因为潘发布了一个重磅消息。新年新糖果，辣玛丽（Hot Tamales），但是你注意到在1分50秒时潘涂了深色指甲油吗？我没注意到。哦，是的。我还拍了照想给你看，然后我做了一次奇怪的小潜水。好吧，我想要你看看，我会把它发到快拍里，但你必须看一看。看看你的指甲。我是怎么蒙混过关的？
in a very intimidating way based on his art. Oh man. Well, that is the cold open, you guys, and we haven't even gotten to the episode yet. Let's get into it because this is a big day. It's a big day for Michael because David Wallace wants to meet him and talk to him about big picture stuff. Michael doesn't really know what that means. It's probably bad. It's also a big day because Pam makes an announcement. New year, new candy, hot tamales, but did you notice at one minute 50 seconds that Pam has dark nail polish? I did not. Oh yeah, I took a picture to show you and then I did a weird mini dive. All right, I want you to see, I'll put this in stories, but you got to see. Look at your nails. How did I get away with that?
他们怎么会允许我这么做？我不知道。因为我只想说，如果我涂着不是那种自然色调的指甲油走进片场，他们早上在化妆车里就会让我把它卸掉。我不知道这怎么就成了漏网之鱼，但我记得你手上涂了这个指甲油。这不是很诡异吗？这是什么？我在网上查了一下，上面说在2008年秋天，指甲油的一大流行趋势是灰色指甲油。事实上，CollegeCandy.com网站说OPI的Sephora系列有一款非常受欢迎的颜色叫“都市时尚”（Metro Chic），那是一种哑光紫灰色。好吧，我想我们都知道。如果要说的话，我绝对是走在潮流前沿的。嘿，你知道时尚潮流的。我知道。我真的是。我想你一定是弄了点“都市时尚”色，周末把它涂在
Why did they let me do that? I don't know. Because I will just say that if I ever came in with a nail polish that wasn't a natural looking nail polish, they would make me take it off in the trailer in the morning. I don't know how this fell through the cracks, but I remember this nail polish on you. Is this so weird? What is it? I looked up on the internet and it said in the fall of 2008, one of the big trends in nail polish was gray nail polish. In fact, CollegeCandy.com said the OPI Sephora had a very popular color called Metro Chic, which was a matte purplish gray. Well, I think we all know. If anything, I'm on trend. Hey, you know the fashions. I do. I really do. I think you got some Metro Chic and put it on
指甲上了。我毫无疑问。我当时没注意到。我超爱OPI指甲油。我一直都涂。我确信那就是那个。我只是不敢相信我居然逃过一检查。你知道的，他们会允许艾米·瑞安和梅洛拉·哈丁作为她们的角色涂深色指甲油，但他们总是希望潘要么不涂指甲油，要么只涂透明指甲油。我大概是偷偷涂上的。也许那天我做发型和化妆的时候一直把手压在屁股底下。好吧，听着，安迪走进来了，他显然为什么事心烦意乱。他想打破房间里的尴尬沉默。我喜欢雷恩·威尔逊饰演的德怀特那种站起来摆出强势姿态的样子。他准备好战斗了，因为当然我们都以为他知道了安吉拉和德怀特有染的事，但那可不是他要说的。他说，你们谁都没有回复我们的婚礼邀请。太尴尬了。在删减片段中，这场戏还在继续，他走到每个人面前说，嘿，菲利斯，你没回复邀请，吉姆，每个人都在假装打电话。哦，不。你有这样一个超级搞笑的单人镜头，你当时说，你一直在躲着他，而且你不敢直视他的眼睛，所以你只看他的鼻子。然后安迪走到你面前问你，而你却尴尬地盯着他的鼻子看，然后他以为自己鼻子上有什么东西。真的太好笑了。这一集的删减片段，我觉得每一个都应该保留在正片里，因为它们都太棒了。吉姆说已经过去17天了。已经过去17天了
your nails for the weekend. I have no doubt. I didn't catch it. I love OPI nail polish. I wear it all the time. I am certain that's what it was. I just can't believe I got away with it. You know, they would let Amy Ryan and Malora Hardin as their characters. They could have a darker nail polish, but they wanted Pam to always like either have no nail polish or just some clear nail polish. I sneaked it in, I guess. Maybe I sat on my hands while I got my hair and makeup done that day. Well, listen, Andy's going to come in and he's clearly upset about something. He would like to address the elephant in the room. I love how Rainn Wilson as Dwight chose to kind of stand up and get in a power stance. He's ready to fight because of course we all think that he knows about
自从圣诞派对上菲利斯说漏嘴以来。大家在茶水间集合，除了安迪，迈克尔说他要去告诉安迪。他必须告诉他。当然，大家都觉得：你不能这么做。这其实是安吉拉的责任。然后我超爱奥斯卡和德怀特之间的对话。哦，我知道。当你要说出这句话时，我就在期待了。而且整个团队开始了解到安吉拉和德怀特在办公室里所有偷情过的地方，这个设定本身就很绝。我们收到了来自杰斯·R的粉丝提问，他说，茶水间里德怀特暗示他一直在和安吉拉在奥斯卡的办公桌上做爱的那个桥段是谁写的？那场戏有即兴发挥吗？没有。完全没有。一点都没有即兴发挥。全都是由简·萨拉达写在剧本里的。太棒了。
this affair that Angel is having with Dwight, but that's not what he says. He says, none of you have RSVP to our wedding. How awkward. In the deleted scenes, this scene goes on where he goes to every single person and is like, hey, Phyllis, you haven't RSVP'd, Jim, and everyone like pretends to be on the phone. Oh, no. You have this hilarious talking head where you're like, you say you've been avoiding him and you can't look him in the eye so you only look at his nose. So then Andy comes up to you and asks you and you're just awkwardly looking at his nose and then he thinks he has something on his nose. It was really funny. The deleted scenes for this episode, I feel like every single one of them should have been in because they were all awesome. Jim says it's been 17 days. It's been 17 days
这场戏把我们带到了会计部。安吉拉显然又在对凯文发火，说他把事情搞砸了。然后有一些真正的凯文式回怼。哦，太棒了。哦天哪。他说，我没意识到自己在做错事。如果我知道的话，我早就承认并立刻停下来了。他在这场戏里真的表现得非常强硬。奥斯卡还夸了他。他说，不，刚才那段真的很好。你做得太棒了。恭喜。珍娜，剧本里紧接着这场戏后面，有一个安吉拉非常生气的单人镜头。这相当惊艳，因为安吉拉愤怒到打破了第四堵墙，痛骂了摄像纪录片剧组，然后还向他们露出了她的一点肩膀。真的吗？是的。萨姆，你能放一下吗？这真的非常重要，需要你获取
since the Christmas party when Phyllis spilled the beans. Everyone meets in the break room, except Andy, and Michael says he's going to tell him. He has to tell him. And of course, everyone's like, you can't. It's really Angel's responsibility. And then I loved the exchange between Oscar and Dwight. Oh, I know. I was anticipating it as you were about to say it. And just the fact that the whole group starts learning where all Angel and Dwight have shagged in the office. We had a fan question from Jess R who said, who wrote the moment in the break room when Dwight implies he's been doing it with Angel on Oscar's desk and was any of that scene improvised? No. No. None of it was improvised. It was all scripted by Jen Salada. So good.
自从圣诞派对菲莉丝说漏嘴以后。大家都在休息室碰头，除了安迪，迈克尔说他要告诉安迪。他必须告诉他。当然，大家都觉得，你不能这么做。这其实是安吉尔的责任。然后我很喜欢奥斯卡和德怀特之间的对话。哦，我知道。在你准备说出来的时候我就已经预料到了。而且整个团队开始了解安吉尔和德怀特在办公室里哪个地方搞过。我们收到了来自杰斯·R的粉丝提问，他说，休息室里德怀特暗示他和安吉尔在奥斯卡的桌子上做过的那段是谁写的，那个场景有即兴发挥吗？没有。完全没有。那段完全是珍·萨拉达写好的剧本。太精彩了。
This scene takes us into accounting. And Angel has kind of given it to Kevin that he screwed up again. And then there's some real Kevin sass. Oh, it's great. Oh my gosh. He's like, I didn't realize I was doing something wrong. If I had, I would have admitted it and stopped right away. He really leans in hard on this moment. And Oscar gives him props. He's like, no, that was really good. You did a great job. Congratulations. Jenna, immediately after the scene in the script, there's a very angry Angela talking head. And it's pretty amazing because Angela is so furious that she breaks the fourth wall and berates the camera documentary crew and then flashes them some of her shoulder. Really? Yes. Sam, will you play it? It's just so important for you to get
这个场景把我们带到了会计部。安吉尔有点把凯文又搞砸了的事情归咎于他。然后有一些凯文真正的傲慢回击。哦，太棒了。哦天哪。他说，我没意识到我做错了什么。如果我知道的话，我早就承认并立刻停下来了。他在这段戏里真的很卖力。奥斯卡还夸了他。他说，不，这真的很好。你做得太棒了。恭喜你。珍娜，剧本里这个场景之后紧接着是一个安吉拉非常生气的单人访谈。这非常惊艳，因为安吉拉愤怒到打破了第四堵墙，训斥了摄像纪录片剧组，然后还向他们露出了她的肩膀。真的吗？是的。萨姆，你能放一下吗？这真的对你很重要
your big story, isn't it? To edit everything together to make it look like there's a villain? Well, there's not always a villain. Sometimes there's just a hardworking, petite woman trying to make a conscientious decision about the rest of her life. Too boring? Did I lose you? Here, is this what you want? Okay, that was amazing. But I have to say, I think it was right to cut it out because I don't know if we've ever had that much direct conversation with the documentary crew before, if we've ever referred so much to what they're doing. I was shocked when I watched it, Jenna, because she's like, is that what you want? You're going to edit this together. You're going to make a villain.
And also, it was a little bit too sophisticated for Angela Martin to understand the whole process of a documentary and how they tell it through narration in these moments. So I think it was the right move to cut it, but I was shocked when I saw it. I had to share. So Angela, I love this episode because there's just so much tension, and it plays out so slowly over when or whether or not Andy is going to figure out that Angela's having an affair. So he has this exclamation on the phone, and everyone's like, but it's really just about the cake. He's just having an issue with the cake. But this leads to that Dwight talking head, because Dwight is on guard this whole time.
He's like constantly leaping out of his chair. And he kind of explains that there are these 40 rules that all shrewd boys must learn by the age of five. And one of these rules is like, don't put your back to a man who you've wronged. That's just one of the 40 rules. Mm-hmm. Don't turn your back on a bear or a dominant turkey during mating season. Yeah. There's a lot of things you shouldn't turn your back on. And then he has this little jingle that he sings. Now, Angela, is it true that Rain improvised that song? Oh, no. That was in the script. That was 100% written. They shared in the DVD commentary that
Rain was singing the jingle a few different ways. And then Dean asked Jen, Jen, how did you hear it when you wrote it? She's sort of saying it her way. And they found it in the moment. So they found the melody, but the words were written. The words are totally written. They're in the script. This is like fabulous Jens Selotta writing. They just improvised the melody. Got it. Well, now Dwight is going to signal Angela to meet him in the hallway. He does this by moving his little bobblehead to the other side of his desk. Yes. He's going to confront her. He wants her to tell Andy the truth. Angela has a line, Jenna, that really made me laugh. She's like, this is a terrible idea. One of your worst. And then he's like, just get it over with. And then
Angela says, you're expanding on your worst idea. That just really made me laugh. Well, Michael is leaving now and he asks Andy to walk with him. Yeah, he's going to do it. He's going to do it. He can't not do it. This is like true, Michael. Like he can't not. The scene is so funny. It's so funny. I mean, it's so perfect. You know, I believe Angela, originally in the scene, he is supposed to tell Andy before he got in his car. Yes, it's scripted that he tells him outside of the car. But on the day, they came up with the idea that it would be really funny if Michael was in the car and then he sort of says it through the window as he's driving away. And that is so good. Yes. So in the commentary, Dean said he
had the idea in the moment that the scene takes place with Michael in the car. And then Steve sort of built on that and was like, what if Michael really doesn't want to tell him? So it's kind of like as he's pulling away. And then Dean said that Steve really peeled out of the parking lot. They did not add that sound in in post. That's actually the car peeling away. That's amazing. Well, we had a fan question from Maria M about this scene. She said, is there a production related reason why the vehicles in this episode all appear so dusty and dirty? And when I went back and looked at it, yes, they're all covered in grime. Yeah, they're filthy. I asked Randy Cordray about it and he said, yes, Maria. Great. I,
to detail, all of the cars were purposely dirtied by the scenic painting crew using flour and water. And this was meant to simulate what cars might look like during a typical scranton winter from just road grime and salt. And snow. Yes. When snow gets dirty looking, right? And it's on your car. Yes. And that the cars in the parking lot belonged to our crew members. And any crew member who volunteered to park their car in the lot got a free car wash every Friday. Oh, how about that? So during the week, they'd have to drive around with a grimy car. But on the weekends, you got a fresh clean car. Well, I think this is a good place to take a break because Andy knows the truth. And when we come back, we'll talk about what he does. Oh, man, it's a lot. This was some
cringy stuff to watch. We'll be right back. All right, we are back. And guys, Meredith knew something big was going to happen today. Now, she said that yesterday, but she was also right yesterday because her neighbor was murdered. What is her life? I don't know, but Meredith has the best, like, throwaway lines. It's like her and Cree. Like, what the heck is their life? It must have been so fun to write for them. I know. At eight minutes, 42 seconds, we get a really good shot of Meredith in this episode. And she is wearing a sweater vest. Yes. Lady, I wore that same sweater vest to a press event with John Krasinski in New York. What? Yeah. I walked on set this week. We were shooting the duel and I looked at Kate
dressed as Meredith and I thought, oh my God. Oh my God, did I make a terrible mistake? I thought it was fashionable. I wore that same vest over this like big poofy white blouse with big poofy shoulders. This was the style. What? It was actually a really expensive vest. It was like Betsy Johnson or something. Can we do a side by side of you and Meredith? We must. Jenna in real life has the same fashion choices as Meredith. Lady, look, here's a picture. Look at it. See? Look at it. Oh my God. First of all, you and John look 14 years old. We have to put this photo in Office Lady Stories. You are wearing Meredith's sweater vest and John looks like he could host Blue's Clues. He does. He's in like a stripy polo. Yeah. Oh my God. You guys look 14 years old.
We were doing press at this NBC Experience store showing off all the new office merchandise. Meredith called. She wants her sweater vest back. Oh my gosh. And like I'd already done the event. You know? Well, you could have heard a pin drop when Andy walked back into that bullpen and he goes over to Angela and says, we need to talk. And she's like, we can talk right here. He's like, no, no. Ed played it so real. I was sweating. I was sweating it. I felt it. We went into that conference room and he shut the door and we were in there a long time and Ed broke my heart as Andy when he was like, do you love him? And I was really feeling all of this emotion and then Angela has to make this plea, this plea to him to don't give up on us. And Jenna, it was all going great until we got to two
words. Formal chrysanthemums. I couldn't say it. Formal chrysanthemums. Formal chrysanthemums. I really had to break it down to be able to say it. But you need to say it like it's effortless. But I literally was like going formal chrysanthemums. You know what, lady? That is not anything having to do with your accent or you. I challenge anyone to say that word. I can't chrysanthemums. Say it quickly, guys. Formal chrysanthemums. That was my best effort, by the way. I mean, literally Jen Salata had to come in the room and help me break it down. But try saying it quickly while you're like throwing it away, like you have no problem saying it in a speech where you're pleading to save your relationship.
And you know what? It wouldn't have worked any other flower. That's the funniest flower. It had to be that. I know. Well, while this whole Andy and Angela scene is going on in the conference room, there's a flip side to what's happening. It's everyone in the bullpen watching. It was deleted for time. It's so great. And I really feel like Phyllis summed up the whole moment perfectly. Phyllis, why is it taking so long? He found out this little angel has been screwing the bead farming weirdo. He's trying to make a make sense in his brain. And then he's going to come out here and kill you. Thank you, Phyllis. You're welcome. Oh yeah, she got it. I mean, that made me laugh really hard. I wish it had stayed in.
Well, this takes us to corporate. Andy and Angela are going to stay in the conference room. They're not done. But meanwhile, we cut over to corporate and we see the reason why David Wallace is called Michael in. He says to Michael, Scranton is outperforming the other branches. Everyone else is struggling. And we want to know, what are you doing right? What is Michael doing so right? I mean, everything in Michael lit up like a Christmas tree. He's like, David Wallace wants advice from me. Yeah. And then he starts talking. Oh, Jenna, I have to read it. Can I please read it? Please read it. The minute he said, David, here it is. My philosophy is basically this. And this is
something that I live by. And I always have, and I always will. Don't ever, for any reason, do anything to anyone for any reason, ever, no matter what, no matter where, or who, or who you are with, or, or where you are going, or where you've been, ever, for any reason, whatsoever. What is he saying? What is he saying? I went to the script. This was not scripted. What? There was a different moment. There was the same thing where he sort of started to talk nonsense. I think Steve was also improvising here. I think he went off what Jen had. And then I think they let Steve do his thing. And now his talking head where he says, sometimes I start a sentence and I don't even know where it's going. I just find it along the way. That was 100% scripted.
The improvisation? Yes. That was all exactly scripted. But this answer to David, I think, was a little bit on the page. And then they just let Steve play. I love it. This little scene between Michael and David Wallace was important story-wise because it's really starting to set up the economic struggle slash decline of Dunder Mifflin, which is going to play out in future seasons as branches start closing, as we get bought out by Saber, spoiler alerts, I guess you're supposed to say that first. Yeah, that's supposed to come first. And also, you start to learn that David Wallace might be in a precarious position. Yeah. So we made it a comedy moment with Michael suddenly giving advice to David Wallace.
But this was also setting up a broader story that we will play out. In the DVD commentary, Dean said one of his notes for all of the Michael David scenes in this episode was, no matter what, Michael won't leave the office, no matter what. Well, that makes sense because he suggests they order some pasta. And then my favorite thing is, like, after that pasta eating scene where Michael is still just going on and on and on, David Wallace kind of gets up and then Michael keeps eating his pasta and David is like, no, no, yes, go, I guess, just finish your meal there. Yeah, I mean, like, pass him on the shoulder and shuts the door and sits back down.
Well, when we get back to the office, Angela and Andy are still in the conference room. She needs him to know that her and Dwight did not do anything fancy sexually. Well, Dwight tells Michael something very differently about their sex life earlier. Oh my gosh, I can't believe we didn't bring that up. That made me laugh so hard, Angela. Yes, Michael is all asking Dwight, like, if she's crazy in bed, crazy in the sack. Is she crazy? And Dwight's like, yes. And then Michael is like, how? How is she crazy? And Jim's just standing there. Yeah, Jim is like, oh God, no, no. And then Dwight says, eager and flexible. Lady, is that in the script? Was that an improv? It's 100% scripted.
It was so good. All of those beats. That made me laugh all out. Some of John's reactions as Jim are improvised, but everything else is scripted. Well, Angela doesn't tell Andy any of that stuff. She just says she loves him. And when he leaves the conference room, he tells Dwight, it's over. It's over. And he means over between you and Angela, not me and Angela. He's still going to marry Angela. Well, Angela made a big case. She was like, listen, we're out of crossroads here. Let's prove all these people wrong. Dwight makes a big declaration that Bernard will never be her last name. They are going to stay together. He is not going to give up. Jenna, this was a much longer
scene. And when Dwight says a duel, we'll have a duel over Angela. The winner gets Angela. Angela, Stanley can't take it anymore. He's going to call BS. And he has this great moment. Okay, we're not doing that. Hang on, Pam. Andy, do you fully understand that the prize is Angela? So help me God, I do. And Dwight, do you fully understand that the prize is Angela? I do. I say give them both guns. Stanley. Darwin, baby. Darwin. Darwin, baby. Darwin. I just love that moment. Even Pam turns to Angela and is like, you have to stop this. But Angela says, I will respect the results of the duel. So yeah, I remember us shooting this moment,
Jenna. But in my mind, there was more to the scene. I went to the script and there was an alt of this moment where Pam confronts Angela. It didn't make it in. And you have a whole speech. And I called it preach, Pam. This takes place in the break room. Okay, Angela. What? You have to put a stop to this. I admit at first, I was blaming you for being selfish and dishonest. But then I decided to put myself in your shoes. I didn't ask you to do that. I get it. You're having a hard time choosing between Dwight and Andy for reasons that you must have about that. But you have to make a decision, Angela. Who would you rather go home to at night? Who would you rather wake up with in the morning? Marriage is a big deal, Angela.
Who do you see as the father of your children? Who are you most proud of? Who's most accepting of your quirkiness? I don't see how any of that matters now. Why not? Two men are about to fight for my hand. And when it's over, I will respect one of them and pity the other. Decision made. Wow. Yeah. I mean, Pam like really tried to show up for Angela in this moment, tried to empathize with her and what, you know, you guys are hearing it. But if you watch it, if you go to the deleted scenes on the DVD, you see all of this emotion go across my face. I'm clearly torn. And it just really showed something you don't get to see that much in this.
You only see little moments that Angela is really struggling. Yeah. Well, Angela, when I was trading messages with Jen Salata about this episode, she was very complimentary of your performance. Oh, she said that this episode was tricky and a lot rested on how your character would react to these two men dueling over her. She said she was really worried. Like, how do you convince people that you would accept the results of a duel? It's so crazy. Yeah. And she said, you know, there was this scene that really shows you stuffing down your real feelings. But she said that you were able to play it so perfectly in just your one line in the bullpen. We so believed that your character would accept
the results of a duel that it grounds the whole episode. And she was so grateful for your performance. Oh my gosh, that's so nice. Thank you, Jen. Well, you know, what I thought about Angela is that she really loves Dwight. She really thinks Andy is a better partner for her, like socially, sort of acceptable and all of that. And she's really struggling about what's the right thing to do in her life. And the duel for her is actually a relief. Because now she doesn't have to decide. To her, this is like an institution that will decide for her. And she's off the hook. And I think that's why she was so willing to accept it. We had some people write in wondering, were you secretly rooting for one man over the other? Do you think Angela Martin was secretly
rooting for one person? I think she was hoping Dwight would win for her. I just have this feeling that on paper, Andy Bernard is more presentable to her family, right? And makes more sense to Angela Martin's family and that they would be more accepting and more willing to embrace Andy Bernard than Dwight Shrut. And so I feel like she could go to her family and be like, well, Dwight bested him in a duel. So, you know, clearly Dwight is the dominant man. And I have no doubt that your whole family would accept the results of the duel. Yes. And I have to go with that. So, you know, I mean, I know we all thought Andy was the one, but I don't think Angela ever thought Andy was the one. And so I think she thinks her family would accept it too. Is that crazy?
But that's what I was thinking. Yeah. So she's rooting for Dwight to win this duel because she loves him more and because it would help gain acceptance with her family. Exactly. Well, this duel is happening. It is happening in the parking lot at 4pm. Bring the weapon of your choice. Yeah. So it's four o'clock. The duel is beginning. Dwight's outside in the parking lot. He's yelling, Andy, where are you? You know, he's like, are you a coward? Everyone else is upstairs watching from the conference room. Angela's saying, I can't believe two men are fighting over me. And then Kelly like has a dig. She's like, well, I guess when you're old, you run out of options or something like that.
I thought that was really funny. Yeah. Oscar doesn't think Andy's going to show. And they're actually kind of placing bets. And Kevin's like, come on. But then Dwight sees a note on some bushes. He goes over to read it. What is this? Yeah. What's this note about? While he's reading it, Andy does show up very slowly, very quietly in his Prius. Well, you know, Jenna, Jen had that one sentence that she had to write this whole episode off of, right? Yeah. About the duel. This was Paul Lieberstein's idea about the Prius. He said, if you go under five miles an hour, it's totally silent. And so this is the weapon Andy chooses.
Yes. He is going to pin Dwight up against the bushes. He's going to crush him. But really, he's only crushing like from his kneecaps down. Yeah. But he's pinned. I mean, Dwight can't move. Dwight can't hit him with his bike chain anymore. Yeah. So he starts slamming it on the hood of the car. They're screaming at each other. At 18 minutes, 16 seconds, Rain shared on the DVD that during this whole screaming match between the two of them, they improvised for about 40 minutes. Dean said at least 40 minutes, just insults and banter back and forth at each other. Dean said there was so much good stuff. I wish we could see that. The 40 minutes of them yelling at each other.
I would watch it. Sure. They're probably amazing. Well, we got a lot of questions about how did we do this scene? How did we do this stunt? Who was driving? Yada yada. Well, I talked to Dean and he said this was really complicated because we had to shoot this scene over two different days from three different locations. First, we shot in the parking lot with Rain and Ed. They performed the whole thing. We shot it and the rest of us were upstairs in Paul's office looking out that window and the camera could whip up to us. In real time. In real time. Yes. We watched all of it. Then they moved the cameras up to Paul's office to get really tight shots out of the window onto the action below and Rain and Ed had to do it all over again
just to get a few little shots through the window. But then on a different day, we shot inside the actual Dunder Mifflin conference room and this time we had to be careful to not shoot out the window because there was nothing there. It was just a backdrop and that we were basically looking at nothing. But Dean was shouting out all the action that had happened the day before. Right. He said this was the moment when being an editor on the show really helped him. He had kind of cut this whole thing together with a shot list inside his head and he just kept telling people, trust me, trust me, trust me, trust me. He could see it, right? He could see it. He could see the whole thing. He said he planned
all of these whippan cuts between the window, between us, all of it. And when he got in the editing room because he edited this episode as well, it actually did all come together and it looked really, really seamless. Well, you have to think that Randy Cordray was like, I knew it. I knew it. Yes. That Dean's editing was going to come into play here. This is why Dean has to direct this episode. But he did say it was a little grueling for the actors because we had to play these same moments over and over and over again more so than we normally do and we had to make it seem like we were doing it for the first time every time. Now, as for the stunt, Randy told us that Ed actually drove the Prius silently through the
parking lot. He said they had stunt doubles standing by for the actual moment of impact. They thought that they would have a stunt driver actually drive into a stunt Dwight. And then after they were kind of squished, they would place rain into the bushes. And Ed into the car. Yes. But then on the commentary, didn't Rain say they just kind of ended up doing it themselves? Actually, the commentary was Rainn Wilson, Jen Salata, Dean Holland, and Rusty Mahmood, who was our first assistant director. And they discussed that Ed actually drove into rain very slowly and that it totally worked. And those takes of those guys actually doing it were their favorite. So those were the ones they used and they did not use
takes with the stunt people. Well, we also got a fan question from Samantha T who wanted to know what was up with the fence? Like what was on the other side of it? Was it padding? Was it an actual fence? Was the bumper of the car padded? Was Rainn really being squashed? Well, it was the real bumper of the car. And then Rainn sent in an audio clip to tell us a little bit about the bushes. Oh, I'm so glad you guys are doing the dual fantastic, one of my very favorite episodes. And I always loved those episodes where Dwight and Andy got to go head to head. I just loved that, that subplot of that, that tension. And Ed Helms is so funny in this episode. But you know what it reminded me of is in college, we studied clowning and
Comedia dell'arte. And it really is classic, old, old comedy, like back from Comedia dell'arte and the Greeks and ancient clowning of two idiots going at it over absurd and in this case, love and a Prius. It was so much fun to shoot. I don't remember a lot of specifics about it, but I remember the hedge had a lot of give in it. So you could really pretend like you were pinned. But it was just a big mass of vines and it was actually very soft and comfortable. And I love that line about the bears in Scranton. So fantastic. So I guess Rainn was quite comfortable being pinned against the bushes, no complaints. Well, I can tell you about those big giant hedges. One time, Brian in a scene as Kevin nudged me, he thought it was a nudge. I went flying
into them. I don't know if you remember that. I can't remember what episode, but I can attest to the fact that it's a very deep, dense, very sort of a hedge you could fall into without getting to the other side. Well, the hedges might have been a good thing for Rainn. They were a nice soft place to land, but they actually caused a little bit of a headache for our production. So Rusty Mahmood, our first assistant director, shared on the DVD commentary that we had about six hours a day to film these parking lot scenes. That's what they had allotted for the time. And by the time we got to the parking lot scenes on the first day of filming, those big hedges had cast a shadow over half of the parking lot. If you go and watch, Jenna, you'll see.
Okay. There's a huge shadow. Well, now guess what? We needed to match that shadow exactly the second day we filmed. Yeah. Right? So in order to do that, they had to create this fake shadow. We have fakey shadow. Fakey shadow. Fakey shadow. They used giant 20 by 20 bounce cards and positioned them behind the hedges on the street so that the shadow would cast and match each day we filmed in the parking lot. Gosh, those are things you just don't think about. I know. But this is the amazing thing about your crew. Someone was like, oh, hold up. That shadow is not going to match. We've got to recreate a shadow. Amazing. Well, fakey shadow wasn't the only fakey thing we had in the scene. We also had
fakey bicycle chain. Fakey bicycle chain. That's right. Clearly Rainn could not whip around a real bicycle chain. So Phil Shea had a rubber bicycle chain made and that's what Rainn used as Dwight to hit the Prius and wave around. So obviously a rubber bicycle chain is not going to make the same sound as a real bicycle chain on metal. So all the sounds you hear are put in post that whopping sound. Except for the car horn. Oh, yeah. Ed was really blaring the horn. I know. Poor Rainn. I know. But he was really having fun with it too because he'd wait and blare it right when Rainn started to talk. Well, all of this mayhem is going on and Jim has a talking head where he's just kind of standing there and you can hear it all in the background.
Oh, yeah. So good. Dean told me that they came up with that idea on the day. He said that as he and Jen Salada were standing there just listening to these two guys go on, he thought it would be really funny to add that. So he and Jen came up with that and they positioned John and they just kind of added that in the moment. It's so perfect because it's the voice of reason. It's this totally normal rational person reacting to this moment of chaos and I feel like it lets the audience take a breath and be like, oh, yeah, this is crazy. Well, in this argument, Andy ends up revealing that he and Angela have had sex, which is something that Dwight did not know. Well, yeah, he says, I can't believe she's been sleeping with you this whole time and she's only slept with me twice.
Oh, yeah. So good. Dean told me that they came up with that idea on the day. He said that as he and Jen Salata were standing there just listening to these two guys go on, he thought it would be really funny to add that. So he and Jen came up with that and they positioned John and they just kind of added that in the moment. It's so perfect because it's the voice of reason. It's this totally normal rational person reacting to this moment of chaos and I feel like it lets the audience take a breath and be like, oh, yeah, this is crazy. Well, in this argument, Andy ends up revealing that he and Angela have had sex, which is something that Dwight did not know. Well, yeah, he says, I can't believe she's been sleeping with you this whole time and she's only slept with me twice.
I made a sex tracker. Oh my God. I did. Oh, no. Here's what I'm going to say, Angela. Oh. In the business trip episode, Andy told Oscar he had never had sex with Angela. In the surplus, Andy says he has seen Angela naked zero times. So we have to imagine that either they've had sex twice since the surplus or they've had sex twice since business trip, but that while having sex, he never saw Angela naked. Which one do you think it is? Fully clothed sex or naked sex recently? You know what? I believe both. I believe that he could possibly have had sex with her, but she wouldn't let him see her naked. Like she'd have some kind of like long gown on, but I also can believe that after Dwight hoodwinked her into
this fake wedding that she was furious and she went and had some revenge sex. I think that's most likely. That's when they had their sex. Yeah. Well, Andy is going to return to his desk. Dwight returns to his desk. They're both crestfallen. Yeah. I mean Dwight feels betrayed and Andy feels betrayed. But who won the duel? Angela's standing there. She hears Andy make a phone call. Well, he cancels the wedding cake. Yeah. It's the one that was in the shape of a sailboat. Yeah, that one.
That wedding cake. Jen said they did have an alt cake line where he would say it was the one in the shape of the letter C for Cornell. Oh, I was like for cat. I know. But they went with sailboat. Then Angela looks to Dwight. Did he win? Hmm. He puts his bobblehead in the trash. Jenna, there was a deleted scene that comes after this where Angela goes up to Pam and she's teary-eyed like her voice is wavering and she says, um, can you give me a right home from work today? Because I no longer have a right home. Yeah. And Pam says yes.
Yes. And then her and Jim give Angela a right home. Oh my God. This car ride, we did shoot the scene. It's in the deleted scenes. Angela just barks directions angrily at Jim. And then she starts sobbing in the backseat and then she's angry again. Well, I'll never forget shooting this scene, Angela, because I mean, this was a whole location day for us. You know, we had this location that was your house and we just dropped you off outside. But they had this really funny joke that there would be like a dozen cats in your window staring out the window at you expectantly as we drop you off. And it was so funny.
It was so funny. I remember they, you know, they had to get a house with like sort of a big front window, like a bay window that all the cats could be in so that we could see them from the street. But then you guys, as we were trading messages with Randy Cordray about this episode, he sent us the casting sheet of the cats and all their headshots. It's a sheet of like cat headshots. Yes, you guys. And here are the names of the 12 cats that played Angela's cats. Potato, Prada, Echo, Flame, Prophet, Whisper, Milkman, Sushi, Roswell, Harvey, Hannah, and Milton. And Roswell looks just like sunny cat. He does. My cat. Yeah. We have to put that photo in stories. And also Randy sent us the photo of Angela Martin's house. Yes. So unfortunately,
太搞笑了。我记得他们，你知道的，他们必须找一栋带那种大前窗的房子，比如凸肚窗，所有的猫都可以在里面，这样我们就能从街上看到它们。但随后你们啊，当我们和兰迪·科德雷就这一集互发消息时，他给我们发了猫咪的演员表和它们所有的定妆照。那是一张猫咪定妆照的表格。是的，你们看。以下是扮演安吉拉的猫的12只猫的名字：Potato、Prada、Echo、Flame、Prophet、Whisper、Milkman、Sushi、Roswell、Harvey、Hannah和Milton。而且Roswell长得跟Sunny猫一模一样。确实如此。我的猫。是的。我们得把那张照片发到快拍里。而且兰迪还给我们发了安吉拉·马丁家的照片。是的。所以很遗憾，
the scene was deleted, but the cats can get their moment of fame. And we got to do a driving scene together. We did. It's very cute because at the end, after we drop you off, Pam turns to Jim, and she says, you know what? I'll call her later to check up on her. And Jim says, she'll hang up on you. Yes. And Pam says, I know. Well, that would have been our alt tag, right? The car ride. Instead of Jim collecting Dwight's weapons. But also right at the end, Michael had a great talking head. Yeah, he's standing on the streets of New York. And he just sort of says, you know, exciting things can happen when you leave Scranton. Just kind of sums up this storyline for him. Well, got a little tidbit from Randy. I didn't notice it the first time I watched it. But in hindsight,
那个场景被删掉了，但猫咪们可以迎来它们的成名时刻。我们还一起拍了一场开车兜风的戏。拍了。非常可爱，因为最后，把你们放下车后，帕姆转向吉姆，她说，你知道吗？我待会儿给她打电话看看她怎么样。吉姆说，她会挂你电话的。是的。帕姆说，我知道。嗯，那本该是我们的备用结尾对吧？车程。而不是吉姆收缴德怀特的武器。但就在最后，迈克尔有一个很棒的单人访谈镜头。是的，他站在纽约的街头。他只是说，你知道的，当你离开斯克兰顿，激动人心的事就会发生。这基本上概括了他在这集里的故事线。嗯，从兰迪那里得到了一个小道消息。我第一次看的时候没注意到。但事后看来，
it was obvious to me. Oh, yeah. This scene was a cheat. Steve was not in New York. Steve was shot on a green screen. And we digitally added the office building scene behind him. Randy said we hired this New York based cinematographer named Alan Pierce to go out and shoot the exterior of a New York office building with people walking by. Randy said it was this awesome shot. But we ran into a problem with the cameras on our end. So for all you techies out there, we would shoot our show on a Sony 900 digital camera. It was a very early generation digital camcorder. And I guess these cameras had very poor color latitude. Oh, sure. Jenna, you know color latitude. I know. I know. And when it's not good, it's it can be tough. I mean, we know. Oh, yeah. How many times
对我来说这很明显。哦，是的。这场戏是个障眼法。史蒂夫不在纽约。史蒂夫是在绿幕前拍摄的。然后我们在他身后数字合成了办公楼的场景。兰迪说我们雇了一位名叫艾伦·皮尔斯的纽约摄影师，去拍纽约办公楼的外景，拍路人走过。兰迪说这是一个非常棒的镜头。但我们在摄像机技术上遇到了问题。所以对于你们所有技术控来说，我们是用索尼900数码摄像机拍摄我们的节目的。那是很早期的一代数码摄像机。我猜这些相机的色彩宽容度非常差。哦，当然。珍娜，你懂色彩宽容度。我懂。我懂。当它不好的时候，真的很难熬。我是说，我们懂。哦，是的。我有多少次
have I struggled with my color latitude? So many. It does not do well shooting on green screen. And Randy said that's why we did it so infrequently. Now, normally, we would just find some place in downtown LA to double for New York. But I noticed on the call sheets that we only had Steve for two and a half days this week. He worked Monday, Tuesday and part of Wednesday. And the whole rest of our shoot was really dedicated to that complicated parking lot scene. I asked Randy about it. He said he doesn't know exactly why we chose to go green screen, but he has to imagine that we just simply did not have time to go downtown and get that shot because it was a complicated shoot week. Well, I didn't catch it on my first watch, but I really did on the second one. Me too. I was like,
为我的色彩宽容度苦恼过？太多次了。它在绿幕前拍摄的效果不好。兰迪说这就是我们不常这么做的原因。通常情况下，我们会在洛杉矶市中心找个地方来假冒纽约。但我注意到在通告单上，这周我们只有两天半的史蒂夫时间。他周一、周二和周三工作了一部分时间。我们拍摄的其余大部分时间都留给了那个复杂的停车场场景。我问过兰迪这件事。他说他不知道我们为什么精确地选择使用绿幕，但他猜想我们只是简单地没有时间去市中心拍那个镜头，因为那是拍摄很复杂的一周。嗯，我第一次看的时候没发现，但第二次看的时候真的看出来了。我也是。当时我就想，
oh, that's Fakie backdrop. There you have it. Fakie building, Fakie shadow, Fakie bicycle chain. Real feelings, guys. That's the duel. That pretty much sums up the duel. All right. Well, thank you to everyone who contributed to this episode. Thank you, Ryan Coe for calling in and giving us the story of your tragic fall. Yes. Thank you, Ryan. And we're going to be back here next week, guys. We have Prince family paper. I'm going to be honest, I do not remember the plot of that one. Who's Prince? Who are they? We're going to find out next week. We're going to find out. I feel like a real audience member. I don't know what's coming. I'm sure I'll remember after I watch the episode, but I can't wait. Hopefully. I hope so. See you
哦，那是假的背景。你们瞧。假的建筑，假的阴影，假的自行车链条。真情实感，伙计们。这就是决斗。基本上这就概括了这场决斗。好了。谢谢所有为这一集做出贡献的人。谢谢瑞恩·科伊打电话进来跟我们讲你那悲惨摔倒的故事。是的。谢谢瑞恩。我们下周还会在这里跟大家见面，伙计们。我们要讲普林斯纸业公司。说实话，我不记得那一集的剧情了。谁是普林斯？他们是谁？我们下周就会知道了。我们会知道的。我觉得自己就像个真正的观众。我不知道接下来会发生什么。我相信看完这那一集我就会想起来了，但我等不及了。希望如此。再见啦，
guys. Have a great one. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、Jenna Fisher 和 Angela Kinsey 制作。我们的节目执行制片人是 Cody Fisher。我们的制作人是 Cassie Jerkins。我们的音响工程师是 Sam Kiefer，副制作人是 Ainsley Bubicoe。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿 (Creed Bratton) 的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版本的 Office Ladies，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用兑换码：office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。